le spitfire et l'un des plus formidables
et des plus célèbres avions jamais
construit encore aujourd'hui il captive
toujours autant le public jeunes et plus
âgés avec sa grâce et sa beauté
il a très certainement inspiré un bon
nombre de personnes à devenir pilote
certains s'étonnent qu'une telle beauté
puisse devenir une machine à tuer et
pourtant si le spitfire a combattu
durant la seconde guerre mondiale sur
tous les théâtres d'opérations de
l'europe au pacifique
il s'est révélé performant dans des
fonctions aussi diverses que celles de
chasseur bombardier ou encore dans des
missions de reconnaissance
en réalité le spitfire fut le seul
chasseur à être produit avant même le
début de la seconde guerre mondiale
et bien après
alors que ses alliés et annie dans le
ciel avait disparu le spitfire continua
d'être développés et ceux en 24 version
différent aujourd'hui une petite
cinquantaine des spitfire continue à
voler alors que près de 22000 fut
reconstruit
l'histoire du spitfire commença dans les
années 30 durant les années qui
suivirent la fin de la première guerre
mondiale les compétitions aérienne de
weert un sport très à la mode
la première de ces compétitions fut le
trophée schnyder et elle fut remportée
par une équipe de pilotes de la royal
air force en 1929
il s'alignait reçurent un hydravion
construit par l'entreprise supermarine
cette firme se forge à un solide
palmarès en construisant ce type
d'appareil ce qui lui permis d'asseoir
sa réputation de constructeur et mérite
à travers ce siècle de conflit
en 1930 super marines associées au
motoriste rolls-royce afin de mettre au
point une nouvelle machine de
compétition les règles du trophée
thunders qui voulait qu'un pays gagnant
trois fois d'affilée cette compétition
conserverait ce trophée à vie
et en 1931 supermarine et rolls royce
s'imposèrent de nouveaux instituts un
nouveau record du monde de vitesse
jamais égalé
l'avion fut imaginée par l'ingénieur en
chef mister original mitchell soutenu
par rolls royce
cette exceptionnelle duo contribuant à
la fabuleuse renommée naissante du
spitfire pendant le trophée schneider
le début des années 30 fut agité en
europe les nazis sous l'emprise
d'adolphe hitler exercer leur pouvoir en
allemagne
ils commencèrent à reconstruire leurs
forces armées malgré les sévères
restrictions imposées suite au traité de
versailles
suivant les clauses de l'armistice
l'allemagne ne pouvait en aucun cas
posséder de flotte aérienne est clair
misant sur le fait que la plupart des
chefs d'état européens refuserait tout
risque de nouveaux conflits autorise à
la construction d'une nouvelle armée de
l'air équipés des derniers prototypes de
chasseurs et de bombardier monoplan dans
l'esprit des anglais
les bombardiers et l arme ultime de
terreur impossible à éliminer
quelles que soient les défenses employés
ceci était dû au fait que les villes
anglaises furent bombardés par les ai
plein et les bombardiers allemands gotha
durant la première guerre mondiale
reconnaissant que leur défense était
devenu obsolète le ministère de l'air
britannique emi un nouveau cahier des
charges pour les futurs chasseur
monoplace
chez supermarine mitchell fort de son
expérience du trophée schnyder
travailler sur les plans des nouveaux
chasseurs
le gros problème était d'arriver à l'eau
g8 mitrailleuse dans une haine aussi
mince que possible afin de préserver les
qualités aérodynamiques du futur
appareil
la solution fut de construire des ailes
elliptique donnant ainsi aux spitfires
en dessin légendaire non seulement les
huit mitrailleuse pour être conservé à
raison de quatre par côté mais les
caractéristiques aérodynamiques se
révélèrent de surcroît exceptionnel
la propulsion fut assuré par un nouveau
moteur rolls royce baptisé tout d'abord
pv 12 il sera connu plus tard sous le
nom de merlat
mais michel fut devancé par l'un des
concurrents de super marine
la firme au coeur et son ingénieur
sydney cam concepteur du week-end
américaine était un appareil tout à fait
conventionnelle bien que monoplan il
était construit de la même manière que
ces élégants prédécesseur biplan des
années 20 et 30
toutefois vers icahn était infiniment
plus simple assemblée de surcroît durant
lé début de la bataille d'angleterre il
se révèle incapable d'encaisser un
nombre invraisemblable de coups au but
sans finir au tapis tant qu'un organe
vital n'était pas touchée
ricken ramener son pilote à la maison
le futur spitfire connu alors sur le
type de 124 était un appareil très
complexe construit à partir de
techniques assurant à la fois légèreté
et rigidité mais difficile à mettre en
oeuvre en temps de guerre
en mars 1936 le modèle 224 a fuit son
premier vol avec le pilote mad summers
aux commandes
à l'atterrissage il déclare à cet
appareil comme parfait et qu'aucune
modification ne lui semblait nécessaire
dès lors en mai la rff commande d'a310
type 224 sans même attendre le compte
rendu des tests
mais d'où le spitfire tient-t-il son nom
et théories divergent
le nom de la firme supermarine
commençons par un ace il fut décidé que
les nouveaux avions porterait à eux
aussi un en commençant par s
plusieurs noms furent alors proposé dans
shrek est chaud heureusement ceux ci
furent écartés est apparu soudain le nom
de spitfire
malheureusement un an après le premier
vol du spitfire et les premières
commandes sans génial créateur hergé
mitchell décéda après un long combat
contre le cancer
son assistant joseph smith pris en
charge l'évolution de l'appareil en août
1938 les premiers spitfire marque un
furent livrés à la rff au 19ème
squadrons basée à tucson près de
cambridge
en europe les événements évoluer vers
une guerre certaines la ville
chamberlain le premier ministre
britannique cherchait des garanties
quant aux intentions d'adolphe hitler en
août 1939 disait ce cadre y furent
équipés de spitfire avec pas moins de
200 appareils
il faut préciser que seuls 150 d'entre
eux étaient effectivement prêts à
combattre
les 77 premier spitfire maca et est doté
d'une hélices bipales a pas fixe à
partir du 78e appareils une hélice
tripale à2pas fut installé l'un des deux
packs correspondant au décollage et
l'autre au vol
les premiers avions furent livrés avec
une verrière particulièrement étroites
ce que les pilotes de grande taille
trouvèrent très inconfortable celle ci
fut rapidement remplacée par une version
bombay qui devint un équipement standard
il y eut également des améliorations à
l'intérieur de l'avion
le verre trempé fit son apparition sur
la canopée et un blindage de 6 mm
d'épaisseur fut placé à la fois derrière
le siège du pilote et sur le tablier
séparant le moteur de l'habitacle
mais un autre problème apparu rapidement
les mitrailleuses avaient tendance à
geler à haute altitude
la solution fut d'abord de réchauffer
les huit mois en ligne et en bouche
ensuite l'orifice des fûts des
mitrailleuses avec un morceau de textile
ciré afin de les garder au sec
jusqu'à ce que les pilotes lâchent leurs
premières rafales
de nombreux pilotes éprouvèrent des
difficultés à s'adapter à ce nouvel
avion
un phénomène de claustrophobie s'empara
par exemple des pilotes habitués au
cockpit ouvert
le train d'atterrissage escamotable une
nouveauté pour certains se révéla
dangereux en effet bon nombre de pilotes
oublié de le descendre avant d'atterrir
avec l'association d'un train
d'atterrissage quelque peu fragile et
d'une voie étroite atterrir avec un
spitfire un fort vent latéral
devenez une manoeuvre délicate de
surcroît un pilote de spitfire devait
lâcher le manche en plein décollage pour
rentrer le train le spectacle
mouvementée d'un spitfire au décollage
aux mains d'un pilote inexpérimenté fait
définitivement partie du folklore de cet
appareil
mais premier vol fut sur sur lequel vous
deviez pompe et qu'on rentre et le train
s'était d'un très stressant lorsque des
colliers pour la première fois avec un
spitfire en même temps que vous comptiez
pour rentrer le train vous deviez sourit
le manche en arrière tout en maintenant
pousser à cet égard une fois le train
rentré hier vous étiez à la fois
terrorisé est très excité
même le roulage demandait un certain
temps pour s'y habituer bien que le nez
de l'avion fut extrêmement gracieux les
pilotes ne voyait pratiquement rien de
vente
la solution trouvée fut d'onduler en
balançant la queue de l'avion de droite
à gauche
néanmoins une fois que les pilotes qui
ont maîtrisé cette caractéristique
il adorait spitfire une des répliques
favorite consistait à dire que vous
faisiez corps avec l'avion autant qu'il
faisait corps avec vous quand vous
montez dans votre voiture vous vous
attachez avec votre ceinture mais quand
vous montez dans un cycle fire vous
attacher le spitfire hauteur de vue vous
devenez une partie du spitfire et le
spitfire devient une partie de vous même
non
on
et la légende a bien failli rester
cloués au sol la complexité à mettre en
production cet avion décida le ministère
de l'air a annulé le programme
heureusement supermarine arriva à
persuader ce même ministère que les
choses pouvaient grandement s'améliorer
grâce à l'ouverture d'une usine
spécifique à castle bridge dans les
médias le 1er septembre 1939 l'allemagne
envahit c'est la pologne le 3 les
britanniques déclarèrent officiellement
la guerre à l'allemagne
le 6 septembre les spitfire de
l'escadrille 74 entrés en action pour la
première fois mais cette première sortie
se termine en tragédie
lorsqu'il à bâtir accidentellement deux
week-ends de l'escadrille 56
ce n'est pas avant le 16 octobre que les
premiers avions ennemis tombèrent sous
le tir des spitfire de juncker liu 88 et
dwayne 15h sens furent abattus par les
spitfire des escadrilles 602 et 603 et
cette période
avare en accrochages fut rapidement
baptisé du nom de drôle de guerre la
grande bretagne attendait de pied ferme
des allemands dont les raids aériens
étaient pour le moins rare le fighter
commandes britannique en profita pour
améliorer sa stratégie
le tragique accrochage des spitfire avec
les hurricanes amenèrent les forces
aériennes à plus de cohésion entre les
différentes escadrille de défense du
seeland
il était essentiel que les opérateurs
radars les observateurs les contrôleurs
et les stratèges transmettent les
informations en temps et en heure pour
que le système de défense aérienne
puisse fonctionner qui aurait pu prédire
à l'époque à quel point les événements
qui allaient suivre pendant l'été 1940
deviendrait si tragique événement que
l'on connaîtra plus tard sous le nom de
bataille d'angleterre pour l' alerte
nous possédions des techniques des
techniques de défense comme les radars
et les opérateurs radars sans lesquels
je pense que nous n'aurions jamais pas
gagné la bataille d'angleterre
car beaucoup de pilotes et d'appareils
furent sauvés grâce à ces techniques et
ont donc pu continuer à voler le radar
nous renseigner quant à la position de
l'ennemi
les opérateurs à se charger de nous dire
quel type combien d'appareils et demi
arrivé en possession
en avril 1940 la drôle de guerre pris
soudainement fin lorsque l'allemagne
envahit la norvège et mois suivant ce
fut au tour des pays bas et ensuite de
la france d'expérimenter la fureur du
bitstream allemand
bien que le chef marshall du fighter
commandes sur you know ding autorise à
quelques escales dry du spitfire à
effectuer des patrouilles offensive au
dessus du channel la grande majorité des
appareils fut conservée pour les combats
à venir
c'était là assurément une excellente
tactique mais elle fut vivement
critiquée à l'époque à la fois par les
pilotes auxquels l'inactivité peser et
par les troupes embarquant sur les
plages de dunkerque sous un déluge de
fer et de feu n'oublions pas que 67
spitfire furent perdues pendant la
bataille de france des pertes que le
fighter commandes ne pouvait en aucun
cas se permettre
de toute façon on a tous fait notre
maximum
on n'aurait pas cher plus on était si
près et si on se souvient bien que vous
pouvez pas aller bien loin
on avait à peine une heure d'autonomie
voire moins on était sur le pied de
guerre dès le lever du soleil et on
rentrait ravitailler et réarmer
peut-être 10 à 11 soit par jour comment
faire plus mais de précieux
enseignements furent tirées de ces
événements ainsi en réalisa que la
tactique de vol à quatre appareils de la
luftwaffe se révéler bien plus efficace
que les formations à trois chasseurs de
la roya la france de même la portée ou
convergence des mitrailleuses pour plus
d'efficacité fut ramené de 3 150 à 200 m
un indice d'octane du carburant fut
notablement améliorée ce qui permis
d'augmenter la vitesse du spitfire de 40
km heure au niveau
r et de 60 kilomètres heure à 3 mm
avec la défaite de la france les
britanniques se retrouver seul le devoir
de repousser l'idéologie nazie peser
soudain sur les seules épaules d'une
poignée de jeunes pilotes
le responsable de la luftwaffe le
maréchal hermann goering était convaincu
qu'il pouvait mettre à genoux la rfa en
quelques petites semaines se trouverait
alors la voie à une invasion terrestre
de la grande bretagne
officiellement la bataille d'angleterre
eu lieu entre le 10 juillet et le 31
octobre 1940 le fighter commandes
comptait 27 squadrons de vie week-end et
19 de spitfire les pilotes venaient d'un
peu partout et pour la plupart étaient
encore de simples novices
il fut rapidement dessiné dès le début
des hostilités que ce serait aux
week-ends d'attaquer les formations de
bombardiers allemands pendant que les
spitfire assurer leur défense face aux
chasseurs dé escortant les combats ont
commencé l'apprentissage était très
difficile alors il fallait apprendre à
voler est quasiment en même temps
apprendre à tirer
durant mes premiers vols sable les
instructeurs me fut relais à la radio de
rompre le combat si j'étais attaqué je
rompais virer à droite ou à gauche
et soudain après cette manoeuvre
je me retrouvais la spéciale avec aucun
appareil en vue du moins fin de mon
squadrons grâce au fur et à mesure que
la guerre avançait on progressait nous
semble une fois notre apprentissage
terminé on entrait dans une période où
l'on arrivait au sommet les démocrates
durant cette période d'apprentissage
on a perdu beaucoup de pilotes mais si
l'on arrivait au bout de cet
apprentissage
on avait alors beaucoup plus de chances
de survivre
le principal adversaire du spitfire fut
le messerschmitt bf 109
ces deux appareils affiché des
performances quasi similaire avec de
petites différences dans certaines
conditions de combat
le spitfire pouvait virer plus courts et
s'avérer légèrement plus rapide jusqu'à
5000 m mais le messerschmitt avait un
taux de montée supérieur et reprenait
l'avantagé en terme de vitesse au dessus
de 6500 m de surcroît le v12 daimler
benz du message tweet était alimenté par
injection ce qui permettait au bf 109 de
bandes dg négatif quelle que soit
l'altitude le moteur du spitfire était
quant à lui alimenté par un carburateur
à flotteurs ce qui nécessitait de la
part des pilotes de savantes manoeuvre
afin de maintenir leur appareil sujets
positifs sans quoi le v12 merlin risqué
de couper faute d'alimentation
j'ai pris en chasse plusieurs et 2009 je
ne sais pas qui avait le plus peur lui
mais on savait déceler quentin 1109
voulait rentrer à sa base qu'il partait
en piqué inversée avec son moteur à
injection le m 109 aimerait prendre des
jets négatif et si vous aviez essayé de
le suivre avec votre spitfire votre
moteur aurait coupé temps que le moteur
reprennent me 109 était déjà loin et
hors de portée mais le principal
inconvénient de messerschmidt était son
manque d'autonomie lors d'un raid à
partir des côtes françaises les
chasseurs allemands décoller puis
consommer inutilement leur carburant en
attendant que les bombardiers d'école à
leur tour et se mettent en formation au
bout du compte les messerschmitt 109 ne
possédait plus que quelques minutes
d'autonomie pour combattre les suites
fire une fois en vue des côtes anglaises
là encore mon expérience personnelle
c'était que les combats entre chasseurs
étaient très courts je ne me souviens
pas avoir eu un long duel avec un sang
neuf
car le même sang neuf en faire
rapidement le combat en partant au
piquet en fait dès qu'on pouvait se
placer derrière un sang neuf ce dernier
rompait en piquant on avait à peine le
temps d'ajuster et de tirer vous pouviez
essayer de le rattraper mais c'était
très difficile car il fallait alors
partir en très léger piquet afin de
prendre un maximum de vitesse
de temps en temps on pouvait atteindre à
son oeuf
mais c'était très rare si vous y
arriviez c'était bien souvent un coup de
chance
le plus souvent on ne pouvait pas bien
que les chasseurs de la luftwaffe soit
numériquement bien supérieur les
appareils anglais volée et combattez au
dessus de leurs propres bases ce qui
leur permettait de rentrer ravitailler
et réarmer plusieurs fois au cours de la
même journée
contrairement aux allemands
cette intense activité fut
particulièrement éprouvante pour les
pilotes britanniques qui bien souvent
combattez du lever au coucher du soleil
la fatigue a été votre compagne de
chaque instant on avait bien à la base
de petits bungalows avec des lits où
l'on pouvait s'allonger
mais la vraie fatigue c'était d'attendre
le plus souvent toute la journée le
bruit de la larme
le plus souvent elle est éveillé depuis
5h30 du matin et on passait la journée à
guetter l'ennemi en fait cette fatigue
le fait d'attendre ce coup de téléphone
qui nous donnait l'ordre de partir en
vol cette fatigue était la partie la
plus stressante du pilote de chasse lors
de la bataille d'angleterre
l'objectif principal de la luftwaffe fut
tout d'abord les stations radar et les
aérodromes situés dans le kent et le
sussex
une fois privé du radar les chasseurs
anglais deviendrai aveugle et incapable
de décoller avant que les bombardiers
allemands soit à portée de vue
fin juillet début août le fatah
commandes se retrouva à deux doigts de
perdre la bataille
le taux de perte des appareils devenant
insupportable mais le maréchal goering
que 8 à cet instant l'une des nombreuses
erreurs qui émaillèrent sa carrière
durant ce conflit
en concentrant les attaques de ses
bombardiers sur londres ce qui donna au
fait à commande le temps nécessaire pour
refaire ses farces
le 15 septembre 1940 la bataille
d'angleterre atteint son point culminant
lors d'une dernière tentative pour
défaire la r f
la luftwaffe lens à des attaques à
répétition pour les anglais résister à
cette offensive signifierait
l'impossibilité pour les allemands de
toute tentative de débat comme la
population regarder en l'air avec
appréhension ces avions qui tissait des
dessins compliqué dans le ciel bleu de
l'angleterre
de temps en temps l'un de s'écraser en
flammes sur terre dix secondes a tiré
sur son adversaire c'était très
éprouvant
ça pouvait même aller jusqu'à 15
secondes
et pendant ce court laps de temps cela
faisait déjà un paquet de projectiles
qui sortait d'une mitrailleuse et canon
et demi et est souvent trop loin et même
s'il était plus prêt ou de rester
difficiles à toucher car il bougeait
nous avons conseillé à un moment de
tirer par petites rafales et de se
repositionner entre chaque petite rafale
sauf évidemment si on était vraiment
prêt de vider nos chargeurs d'un coup et
alors là vous pouviez voir partir votre
ennemi en flammes mais cela reste est
une chose très rare car ccnmi vous avez
le plus souvent repérées depuis mais les
pertes allemandes n'ont cessé
d'augmenter
et fin septembre le haut commandement
germanique commence à sérieusement
s'inquiéter du côté britannique
les pertes étaient aussi considérables
tant en termes de pilotes que
d'appareils 565 rue week-end et 352
spitfire n'était jamais rentré au plus
fort de la bataille les spitfire marque
un commencèrent à être remplacés par des
marques de la principale différence
entre le mark 1 et le mark ii fut une
évolution du moteur merlin qui voyait sa
puissance dépassait désormais les mille
choses aujourd'hui ce mark ii qui volent
sous vos yeux est l'un des nombreux
appareils du musée volant de la bataille
d'angleterre et aussi par ailleurs l'un
des plus vieux spitfire venant au monde
comme beaucoup de spitfire se marquent
deux fûts assemblés à l'usiné de castle
bromwich et rejoignit le conflit au mois
d'août 1940
l'addition au musée volant de la
bataille d'angleterre l'agencement de
couleurs des appareils et changer
périodiquement pour rendre hommage à
tous les soirs dont par exemple la
notation xt des sur les flancs commémore
les avions du squadron georges dancehall
membres de l'escadrille numéro 603
jordan vol fut crédité de la première
victoire aérienne quand un appareil
allemand au dessus du territoire
britannique
toujours pendant la bataille
d'angleterre georges d'un homme de vingt
leaders d'un squadrons basée à en
cherche dans l'essex ait survécu après
avoir été abattu deux fois
mais
il
le
m
un autre exemple ce même spitfire marque
de vol à un temps sous les couleurs du
277 qui fut une unité de recherche et de
sauvetage basé à hawking dans le kent le
retour de ce spitfire dans les rangs de
la rff fut financé par la banque
d'angleterre
les unités de recherche et de sauvetage
fut créée en 1943 les spitfire embarqués
à leur bord un chargement largable
constitué d'un canot de nourriture et de
médicaments pour les équipages a battu
le spitfire pouvait de surcroît
patrouiller sur place en attendant que
le bateau de sauvetage arrivent et
récupère l'équipage en mer
la défaite de la luftwaffe en 1940 ne
permit pas toutefois la rff de passer à
l'attaqué
la série des red connu sous le nom de
rhubarbe fut lancée uniquement dans
l'intention d'attirer les chasseurs
ennemis dans le but de provoquer les
allemands des raids baptisé cirque
volant furent organisées autour d'un
petit nombre de bombardier escorté par
de nombreux chasseurs mais les pilotes
de chasse en anglais -sur une bien
mauvaise surprise lorsqu'ils furent
confrontés à la dernière version du
meilleur schmitt le bf 109 f
cette nouvelle version du chasseur
allemand se révéler très supérieure aux
vingt ricaine et plus manoeuvrable que
le spitfire au dessus de 6500 m
si le travail sur la version mac 3 du
spitfire continuer cet appareil était
bien loin d'être prêt mais il fallait
d'urgence un appareil plus performant
c'est ainsi que naquit le spitfire marc
st
l'esprit trail en marque cinq reçu une
cellule renforcée et une nouvelle
version du merlin qui développait
désormais plus de 1200 cheveux le marque
5 fut également équipé d'un nouvel
armement comprenant notamment deux
canons de 20 mm soit un par m les
projectiles des mitrailleuses blanc
ligne 303 se révélait en effet trop
léger et n'occasionner que de faibles
dommages
toutefois en concentrant un grand nombre
de ces projectiles sur une cible le tout
associé à une cadence de tir élevé on
pouvait compenser le faible impact d'un
projectile seul à canons tirant des obus
de 20 mm pouvait causer bien plus de
dégâts en très peu de temps
en tant à bien à l'époque d'installer
des canons sur les marques 1
mais les vibrations se révélèrent
beaucoup trop importante pour ces fines
mais fragile zen
le problème fut réglée sur remarques 5
en augmentant l'épaisseur relative de
son aile et l'on put ainsi logé un
armement de plus fort calibre le marque
5 pro va rapidement qu'il pouvait être
au moins à l'égal du bf 109
mais la plupart des chasseurs allemands
étaient désormais partie sur le front de
l'est ce qui confirme ayoub la holding
dans sa conviction d'engager le moins de
chasseurs possible dans la bataille
alors que les pertes anglaise devenait
dangereusement significative les reds
allemands furent brutalement suspendu en
novembre 1941 on mettait notre vie en
danger à chaque sortie
mais pourquoi objectivement on avait
exactement les mêmes chances d'être
abattu que l'ennemi si notre circuit
d'huile de été touché pendant la
bataille d'angleterre
mais si on était touché on avait alors
très peu de chances de pouvoir rejoindre
la base
et même si on arrivait à se parachuter
côté anglais on n'avait pas d'équipement
de survie et quasiment aucun bateau pour
venir nous rechercher on se battait on a
perdu beaucoup d'hommes mais à l'époque
on ne comprenait pas la tactique et à
leurs employés
je ne comprenais pas j'allais me battre
devoir patriotique
si on lisait les journaux de cette
époque la bataille d'angleterre était
présenté comme un hymne au mans ce
combat de boxe ça mais on ne pouvait pas
choisir son adversaire
on tirait sur ce qu'on avait la chance
d'avoir dans le 20h à un moment ou un
autre et si on était attaquée on
essayait de s'en sortir on changeait pas
d'altitude pour aller chercher un ennemi
ce n'était pas un jeu mais bien une
guerre une fois engagé on rester
concentré pendant la bataille
d'angleterre au pensé en premier au
danger on faisait surtout attention à ne
pas se faire tirer dessus avant même
d'essayer de tirer sur l'ennemi
tél
aujourd'hui certains marquent cinq vols
toujours y compris cet exemplaire
appartenant au musée volant de la
bataille d'angleterre ce spitfire sortie
de la chaîne de production de castle
bromwich en août 1941 et fut livrée au
squad rang 222 au sein duquel il vole à
de nombreuses années
à partir de 1947 il participa à des
courses de vitesse avant un atterrissage
raté qui mit un terme à sa carrière de
compétiteur
suite à sa restauration par l' usine
vickers
il rejoignit à nouveau les rangs de la
rfa en 1965 place qu'il conserve encore
aujourd'hui
en 2003 ce spitfire marque 5 fut pas aux
couleurs de la déserte air france durant
les premières années de la guerre bien
que la priorité fut de conserver un
maximum de spitfire pour la défense du
sol national
les britanniques lancèrent une grande
campagne à travers le désert du nord de
l'afrique
mais en 1942 la pression de la luftwaffe
au dessus de l'angleterre s'atténue et
la production ont permis que des
spitfire puisse être envoyé sur d'autres
fronts
les premiers spitfire arrivèrent dans
l'afrique du nord en avril 1940 eu lieu
au sein du squad rose 145
il s'agissait du marc 5b équipe et
délices quadri palapa variable et deux
mitrailleuses de 12,7 remplacer
l'armement habituel le moteur merlin
suis préparé de manière à augmenter sa
puissance à haute altitude ce spitfire
porte la livrée du squadrons 224 qui
prit part au combat durant la campagne
de tunisie en 1943
bien que le spitfire soit reconnue pour
ses combats à travers les cieux
européens
il jouera également un rôle important en
protégeant la flotte alliée en mer avant
la guerre la société supermarine
proposant au ministère de la marine une
version navale de son chasseur venait
mais en 1940 wiston churchill avait
ordonné que la totalité de la production
soit consacrée à la défense du pays
la navy attendrait donc
est le spitfire ne pourra jamais se
révéler un avion performant en matière
de porte-avions sont longs et limiter la
visibilité faisant donc de cet appareil
un avion particulièrement difficile à
manoeuvrer sur les ponts des petits
porte avions britannique le train
d'atterrissage était également bien trop
fragile et bien trop étroit pour
supporter les violences atterrissage que
les pilotes de la navy avaient parfois à
effectuer mais une fois dans les airs le
spitfire version navale se révéla au
moins aussi efficace que ses cousins de
la force
et malgré les inconvénients énuméré le
sea fire fut là des plus formidables
appareils à moteur à pistons a jamais
volé le premier 6 fire fut basé sur le
marque 5 mai renforcée pour être
catapulté est muni d'un train
d'atterrissage élargie afin de réduire
les risques de renversement
elle fut également renforcée afin de
pouvoir embarquer des charges et
extérieur le cif ailleurs mark iii
également basé sur le spitfire marque 5
fut le premier à recevoir des ailes
pliant le mark iii fut la version la
plus produite du sea fire à la fin de
l'année 1941 le spitfire fut à nouveau
surclassé par l'apparition d'un nouveau
chasseur allemand le focke wulf f w190
ce feu que vous possédez non seulement
un moteur bmw très puissant mais ils
pouvaient de surcroît virer très cool en
avril 1942 59 spitfire furent abattus le
mois suivant le messerschmitt 1 809
version géante rend service
c'était une version optimisée pour les
opérations à haute altitude
il semblait que le suit d'ailleurs avait
perdu tout supériorité aérienne
afin d'améliorer les capacités en haute
altitude du spitfire l'ale du marque
cinq fûts allonger cette nouvelle
version baptisée marxiste fut également
dotée d'une cabine partiellement
pressurisée la verrière demain fixe et
ne pouvait être largué en vol qu'en cas
d'urgence
mais cette version ne fut pas un succès
et seulement une centaine pu rassembler
mais par un heureux hasard un f w190
atterri à peine créée par erreur cela
donna l'opportunité à la rff de comparer
cet avion un spitfire marque 5 qui se
révèle à supérieur dans bien des
domaines
mais incapables de suivre le focke wulf
en virage serré afin d'améliorer son
taux de roulis l'ale du spitfire fut
raccourcie de plus d'un maire
cette nouvelle aile permis aux spitfire
ainsi modifiée de se montrer un peu plus
rapide qu'un marque 5 standard mais
surtout d'afficher un taux de roulis
considérablement amélioré avec l'ajout
d'un compresseur modifier ce nouveau
spitfire pouvait se permettre de suivre
le focke wulf 190 dans ces évolutions à
basse altitude
bien que le spitfire marque 5 commence à
sa vie en étant mise au point dans
l'urgence il se révèle assez performant
qu'il se construisit plus de mc5 que
n'importe quel autre version du smic
prime
les spitfire marque 8 aurait dû être le
digne successeur du marque 5
cette version est reluisent et les
hélices à quatre pales et la série 60 du
moteur merlin série qui conclut une
légendaire lignée de moteurs d'avions
les merlin 61 montées sur les spitfire
marque 8 sortait plus de 15 cents
chevaux et furent dotés d'un carburateur
modifié permettant des manoeuvres angers
négatif
les marques 8,2 furent envoyés à l'est
et en mars 1944
cette squadrons étaient déjà équipées de
spitfire marque unis
mais ce fut le marque nef qui redonne l
avantage aux spitfire contre ses rivaux
allemands
le march 9 fut le dernier spitfire
équipé du merlin et représente en
quelque sorte l'ultime évolution du
célèbre marque 5
il fut lancé lui aussi dans l'urgence en
attendant que le mark reid soit
définitivement au point on avait une
possibilité de surpuissance sur le
merlin mais uniquement dans un très
court laps de temps et uniquement à très
haute altitude
mais grâce à cette surpuissance si on
voyait elle me 109 pas trop loin on
pouvait alors le rattraper sans être vu
et ça c'était vraiment sensationnel on
se disait je le rattrape
je rattrape quand on en arriver là on
pouvait se dire que l'apprentissage
était fini on commençait alors à prendre
vraiment confiance en soi et c'était là
que cela devenait vraiment dangereux
parce que tu commençais à confondre la
guerre avec un jeu
le premier squadrons à recevoir des
marques neuf fut le squad en 64 à une
charge en juillet 1942
le spitfire marque 9 séries mais la
supérieure au football 190 pour la
luftwaffe cette nouvelle version du
spitfire rendait obsolète le léger
avantage acquis auparavant lors de raids
à basse altitude organisé malgré le
petit nombre de mw 190 qu à l'heure
disponible et au début de l'année 1943
la supériorité aérienne commence a
effectivement a changé de camp au fur et
à mesure que les nouveaux marque neuf
arrivées
des raids aériens pureté leur être
effectuée au dessus de la manche raid
constitué de bombardier boston
escorté de spitfire ainsi au fur et à
mesure que les britanniques reconstitué
leurs forces
l'opposition germanique diminuer les
forces de la luftwaffe tant en hommes
qu'en l'appareil étant de plus en plus
drainer vers le front russe
durant l'été 1943
l' us air force arriva en grande
bretagne et commença à bombarder
l'allemagne en plein jeu durant ces
bombardements d'urnes des escortes de
spitfire furent alloués aux bombardiers
américains mais on se rendit vite compte
du manque d'autonomie du chasseur
anglais ce problème d' escort le fut
résolue qu'avec l'arrivée des mustang
p-51 les performances du mustang furent
considérablement améliorée quand on
décida de l'équipe et du moteur merlin
construit sous licence par pas car les
moteurs construits par pas card furent
également installés sur les marques neuf
rebaptisé du coup marc 16
plus tard l'arrière du fuselage de ses
marques 16 fut modifiée et une verrière
bombay remplace à l'antique canopée
d'origine pour une meilleure visibilité
du pilote
le marque 9 fut le principal appareil à
combattre en europe durant les dernières
années de la guerre le marque 9 joie un
rôle prédominant l'établissant la
supériorité aérienne des alliés à
travers l'europe et ce bien avant
l'arrivée des chasseurs américains tels
que mustang thunderbolt ou p 38
lightning le jour du débarquement le 6
juin 1944 la rfa ligne et plus de 55
squadrons équipés de spitfire suite au
débarquement les spitfire marque 9 du
squatteront 222 furent les premiers
chasseurs alliés a opéré depuis la
normandie où il était arrivé le 10 juin
le 17 juillet les spitfire marque 9 me
trahir une voiture officielle du haut
commandement allemand
à l'intérieur de cette voiture se
trouvait le maréchal erwin rommel
commandant en chef des défenses
allemandes chargé de repousser
l'invasion alliée
romel ressorti de cette attaque aérienne
ans souffrant d'une fracture du crâne
blessure dont il ne se remit jamais
totalement
au début de l'année 1943 les spitfire pu
être équipé du tout nouveau moteur bi
fonds destiné à remplacer le merlin
comme le merlin le griffant était un v12
suralimenté mais capable de produire
d'emblée plus de 1700 cheveux mais le
griffon était plus long de près d'un
mètre et lendu greffer sur le capot
moteur du spitfire de larges
protubérance afin de pouvoir y loger les
nouvelles rangées de cylindres
le spitfire marque 12 équipes et du
griffon permis à la rff de posséder
enfin un chasseur capable de faire jeu
égal avec les phoques wulff à basse
altitude
au début de l'année 1944 le marque xiv
fit son apparition
la version reconnaissance photographique
de ce nouvel appareil fut le marque 19
deux d'entre eux vol aujourd'hui avec le
musée volant de la bataille d'angleterre
comme ce fut souvent le cas dans
l'histoire du spitfire les nouveaux
moteurs furent a couplé aux cellules
disponibles dans le cas présent ce fut
le marque 8 afin de pouvoir profiter de
la puissance du griffon une hélice à
cinq pales fut introduite à l'identique
des marques 16 quelques marques 14 hrs
sur les mêmes modifications de fuselage
et une verrière bombay toujours afin
d'améliorer la visibilité du pilote
le marque 19 fut la version de
reconnaissance photographique du marque
14 totalement désarmés puis il possédait
avec 2500 km franchissable l'autonomie
la plus importante jamais vu sur un
sweat file c'est d'ailleurs un marc 19
qui sera le dernier spitfire destinés à
la rhf à sortir des chaînes de
production en 1954 le mar 14 était un
appareil extraordinaire était à la fois
si puissant et si bruyant que j'avais
l'impression d'être sur une moto mais
une moto qui volent faisait vraiment
corps avec cet avion mais puissant
signifie aussi délicats à piloter
c'était vraiment grisant mais on pouvait
aussi par enthousiasme à en perdre le
contrôle
la version marque 18 tout comme le mac
14 utiliser une cellule de marque 8
équipé d'un griffant doté d'un
compresseur à double étage d'une
puissance de 1300 chevaux se marque 18
reçu par ailleurs une aile capable
d'embarquer plus le carburant
la 20e version du spitfire bien
qu'apparemment très proche de ses aînés
était en fait un appareil profondément
remanié si les elfes une fois de plus
redessiné le poids de cette nouvelle
version était en très nette augmentation
par rapport à ses prédécesseurs
cela nécessitait donc un train
d'atterrissage plus solide
bien que le griffon 61 64 doté d'une
hélice à cinq pales soit devenu
désormais la motorisation de base du
spitfire certains furent également
équipé du griffon 85 version équipée
d'un double et délices à trois pales
contrarotatives les marques 21 et 22
étaient plus rapides de 160 kilomètres
heure que le marqua originel un progrès
considérables réalisés en très peu de
temps le marque 24 fut la dernière
version des spitfire identique au 21 et
22 ans le dot a cependant de
l'exceptionnel canons israéliens ces
dernières versions arrivèrent à la toute
fin du conflit et vire par conséquent
leur production limitée par rapport à
l'évolution du spitfire comme l'a déjà
dit à m chauffe je crois que l'esprit de
son créateur mitchell a disparu après le
marque 9 frei flou j'ai volé sur le mar
14 16 le 19 et le 22
je penserai les derniers spitfire
n'était plus réellement découvert
mais le temps du réacteur était arrivé
et avec lui les jours du spitfire
désormais compter toutefois le
développement du spitfire et du cif
ailleurs se poursuivre au point d'être
renommé avec de bien étranges patronyme
tels que ce pétrole et six femmes
de nombreux enseignements fut retirée du
développement du spitfire ainsi la mise
au point de l'ale dit à écoulement
laminaire servi grandement à la mise au
point du premier jet de la firme
supermarine l'attaquait les spitfire
furent utilisés sur à peu près tous les
théâtres d'opérations alliées durant la
seconde guerre mondiale aussi performant
dans la supériorité aérienne que dans
l'attaqué au sol
le spitfire se révèla même capable
d'abattre les terribles v1 lancé sur
l'angleterre par les allemands à la fin
de la guerre quelques marques 9 fut
reconverti en appareil biplace
d'entraînement
moi
la production du spitfire c'est ça le 20
février 1948
quelques vingt mille trois cent
cinquante et un spitfire et 2408 sea
fire avait été libre
les derniers spitfire fut retirée de
l'inventaire de la ras
en juin 1955 malgré l'énorme quantité
d'appareils assemblée seule une petite
cinquantaine vole encore à ce jour et
bien des chantiers de restauration sont
à l'heure actuelle en cours
nous avons filmé avec beaucoup
d'attention un magnifique vol en
formation des spitfire marque neuf
marques 16 et marc 18 furent rejoints
par un corsaire et nous avons gravé sur
la pellicule
ce moment inoubliable
le chant du merlin et des rares griffon
encore en service nous rappelle à chaque
instant à quel point le spitfire su
allier puissance et beauté à travers le
ciel du monde entier et ce depuis ses
premiers jours de l'été 1940 où l'europe
était à deux doigts de basculer toute
entière dans l'horreur
en ce début de 21e siècle
si un on peut évoquer les heures de
gloire les plus mémorables de la grande
bretagne
c'est bien celui du spitfire
moi